歡迎收看中大膽週報公開版275集
哇
最近的這一個禮拜跟前一個禮拜真的是一個天差地遠的
我們看到大盤指數一度喔
有把這個4萬點大關稍微跌破但是隨即又反攻了
5000點
也要很感謝很多朋友對我們的信任跟支持
這個4萬點真的是歷手
而且是強談
希望大家在這一波的強談裡面
不但資產回血
甚至有逢低減到不少的好股票
很快的 指數又來到4萬5000點附近
當指數來到4萬5000點附近
你現在選擇的策略是什麼
你選擇的策略會決定你接下來
是賺錢一波還是虧錢
我們現在看大凡指數又回到4萬5000點
這一次我在之前的前兩集當中有提到過
時速來到4萬5夫妻
你就是要把時估比重
把它降低到大概5成左右
這次反逃到目前為止
大盤最高的指數是44980
差20點
所以現階段我會建議
把時估比重就降低到
為止我們先前講的5成左右
現在我們要發現到
上櫃融資又再出現增加
上市也是增加
只不過上櫃增加的幅度
真的確實
如果在電視的公開版提到了
他的占比是在近期當中算是最高的
上次你是賣了4萬點
然後現在又買了4萬5呢
還是你是聽我的建議
買在4萬點左右
然後我們賣在4萬5
所以如果你是先賣4萬
再買4萬5
你永遠又再做一次
殺低最高
我們這一波當中你可以發現到
大盤指數已經來到
終極的下漲趨勢線4萬5左右
說這麼來說
總總你不再看未來的
買盤力道是如何嗎
會不會往上攻
我跟各位講
我不會去冒那個風險
低檔5000點
你可以掌握住5000-4000
這邊是差不多你掌握住
你為了後面
大概剩下1000點左右的空間
你要去冒那個風險
只剩1000點嗎
差不多1000點
不要忘記我們之前講個
45000點的整數關卡有上元跟下元
上元就在46500點
頂多讓你上去
也差不多到4600左右
1000點沒把握
5000點
如果你沒把握
很快從45000
又降到4萬4
裡面賺到那1000點
反而他倒賠那1000點
那這波投信過了4萬4以後
他能買超減小
當我在做這個檔案的時候
坦白講投信在禮拜五的買賣
我還不知道
我發現禮拜五投信是賣超
竟然
我發現我真的跟投信的腳步是很相似
很相似 真的
你知道嗎
投信這次終結32次的一個桌子馬鈔之後
上次他能賣超什麼時候
上次他什麼時候賣
48218的前一天
那時候也就是我潑大家人水
連價完之後
我不會去跟大家嗨5萬點
投信就在禮拜我賣
然後接下來48218他也賣
我跟各位講
跟投信都沒有套好招的
全部都是講在前面
然後剛好發現我們的步調
真的是一模一樣
換句話說
我跟投信我們做的就是
高出低接
我們上次跟各位提到過了
你來到4萬3 4萬2以下
你就一路按照逢低成階
到投資源說前面都黑K啊
我管你怎麼黑不黑K
我們上次跟大家都講白的
4萬年500點
就是台灣今年的股票市值
我認為最合理的位置區
所以你破4萬
我會比較領在緊上什麼
因為那個企業獲利是
很明顯的事已經看得到成績
那我認為說投信在低檔會貪貧
包括這是應該算是成功
但是他高檔會再觀望
你投信也知道
這個位置他可能還要再觀察一下
整個國際的局勢變化
我認為量能最近沒有再增加
或許有機會再回測到
4萬2以下的缺口的部分
而長線支撐我會維持在4萬天左右
所以當指數來到4萬5左右
你要最高還是要持續高速低階
我想就看你自己
原則上外資雖然轉買超
但禮拜五他又在賣
整體看起來現在稍微是好一點
不過他的空擔我發現
還是沒有明顯的下降
顯然他還是鎖著部位
那投信價買超變小的話
我覺得個人認為
要拉回到我自己心目中的穩健區
我才會大幅開始提高
整個吃骨比重的部分
那投信的佈局成本大概就4萬4左右
所以你會發現
但他超過4萬4之後你會發現
禮拜五
大家就知道
好不容易開始
吃完4以上
他自己就知道要賣
所以我長期在看投信的買盤成本
你看準不準
那高到他老量重
我認為說量能不足
你還是把他吃骨比重降低
這次我們在地檔分批佈局
超級當中建跌升版台
這是獲利
我建議就順利出場
同樣的未來
大家回到文件區
可以把吃菇比重提高到6成到8成
那來到超級文件區
就來到8到9成
只是超級文件區
你又緊張死了
那投資本人說
下次超級文件區
我就不會再那麼緊張了
如果早知道
我跟你講
就不太會來第二次了
因為
我們這個合作應該
第三年一三年了
看過超級的
也不能說差不多
幾乎每一次都是一樣的循環
下去一開始覺得我要逢第一買
但是到了更下去就會覺得完了
一切都完了
沒錯
都永遠這樣輪迴
快投資朋友你會發現
大多數跟你講分析解盤
就說48118叫高點
所以如果盤頭當位置有壓力
他廢話我也會看
現在跟你講什麼
前波4萬點以下那個叫支撐
為什麼
你看到那邊有指紋上漲
相信你應該都買在4萬2左右
因為4萬1600點
你還覺得到底是真的來假的
但是當你發現
連續能夠上漲的時候
你差不多買到4萬2
換句話說
你買到4萬2
跟我之前在分踢誤舉的時候
都點數的差很多
我們在上禮拜也跟大家直接
開門見山就講
8月份跌升反彈
我不是8月
今天到8月8號9號
這個時候才跟你講說
喔 這樣子叫做跌升反彈
我是在7月底收完盤之後
告訴你8月份會跌升反彈
我是不是都講前面
所以你是要去做一個follower
還是要先做一個所謂的一個leader
就看你自己決定
我們還是幫各位做一個複習
7月份跟8月份沒有連結
所以我們上次跟各位講
你不用因為7月份的大跌
你緊張
所以後來我發現8月份上漲
但是不要忘記一件事情
上次我們之前也提到過
7月份的跌幅
8月份漲幅不容易去超越
我再重複複習一次
2024跌3.62
但8月份只有漲0.31
2021 跌2.86
然後8月份只有漲1.41
今年的7月份大概是跌了6點多
換句話說整個如果這樣算跌幅的話
那麼大概叫3.26
3.26多少
也就是說44525之上
正常來講
8月底應該會落在44525之下
那以禮拜五的來講的話
稍微低300點
如果未來下個禮拜有來到4萬4千5百多點
記住十股比重景低
因為它可能在8月底是落在44525之下
所以這個部分我已經告訴你
然後同樣過去最大的第三季跌幅在9.45
大概落在41765
也就是說正常在9月底之前
應該如果真的那一年比較沒有那麼順利的話
應該會有機會來到41765
那所以換句話說4萬2以下
那個叫做超敵的
所以都講得很清楚了
上次我們提到過
8月份如果大漲
都應該降低持股
那現在是不是大漲
真的是一個大漲
那同樣呢
我們會發現
上次我跟各位提到過
多頭只拉回一個月之後
就會進行一個整理
你會發現前幾次的月收黑
可以完之後
4月也就是說7月份收黑
那8月份的情況
過去除了去年的對等關稅之後
那個狀況比較克服以外
你會發現到先前的幾次都是大黑K完之後
黑K完之後
4月只有小長的部分
他沒有連續下跌
但是會出現一個小幅整理
所以還是一句話
8月份大漲都不一定再追
所謂你學的現在不夠多
那如果你距離學的不夠多
那你就繼續放
繼續放
會從4萬5到4萬4
4萬4再下去
我想這邊我已經講得很白了
同樣不確定的行情
這張圖有些投資朋友給我蠻大的鼓勵
那這張圖還蠻準的
這五六月十一號
不是現在八月份嗎
我覺得現在的話六月二十一號
兩百六十一集
如果你是訂閱護的
或者是公開版看
你有沒有發現
全部都是我現場畫好
四萬六千五百點以上叫做超級積極
四萬三以上叫積極
然後三萬九千五百點
這附近以下叫做超級穩健
同樣的呢
我們上次有跟各位提到過了
四萬五千點在台積電法師位
所以那時候有跟各位提到過
4萬5千點以下
你降低持股
然後呢
4萬3就做穩健區
就是我圖上畫的
就上市我們畫的
那個以下分別就叫各位投資朋友去買
因為我是按照總經
基本面在看的
那技術面我列懂一二
所以大概會算出來這樣子
所以我們這樣看一看
現在在哪個位置區
積極區
所以你發現你最近的買股票
是不是變得很積極
當然你4萬3以下
你哥哥你會相信我
你開始變得不積極
所以如果你持有股票比較低的部分
投資朋友你就等到這個4萬3以下
你再來做把股比重再做提高
另外時間有一線我會再跟在影商本告訴投資朋友
我為什麼在這位置會先踩煞車
這張表現在就讓大家再度的去副盤檢驗一下
6月21號就已經畫好並且給大家看過的標歌
真的就是在這個區間跑
市場就是需要一點反人性的操作跟思維
因為我們這個多年來一直都是用這樣的想法
來幫各位做驅擊避兇
那中大膽在這一波的點位真的抓得非常準
但是我們也理解一件事
就大家在個股的操作上
一定會覺得前一波殺得非常的深痛
到底有沒有機會把殺下去的股票
來回的操作或是能夠做解操或是換股呢
那就歡迎大家訂閱一下我們的 VIP
我會把訂閱的連結放在留言的第一則喔
那就我們VIP見吧